[Music]
so how many you guys have ever been on
like a a Leadership Retreat or like
company Retreat or something like that
where you do certain like activities in
the wild or whatever in order to build
camaraderie yes Mom was too poor for all
that absolutely so you guys I'm sure
have all participated or are familiar
with the trust fall yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah profits what you do okay
so there's a variation of the trust fall
though apparently in this situation uh
that that is different I I I I have to
admit I've never done this one in this
particular trust fall it actually
involves jumping with a type of like
rope and or harness and then trusting a
comrade if you will to be able to either
belay you or catch you in some sort of
that that's way too much yeah it it's
it's a lot more intense does my partner
work at
REI um does partner work at so it's not
just it's not just this and then you
catch it's more like ah
and then and you're waiting and hoping
word for word that says this trustfall
exercise involves one person secured by
a rope stepping off of a 40ft high ledge
40t a [__] repel Tower you could die
from that nah this sounds like American
thing they're supposed to be caught
quote unquote by a person holding the
Rope on the ground the 39th foot
floor now the unfortunate irony of this
it's not irony it's just they have those
bricks of at the bottom or some [__]
like that maybe not foam just n this
just [__] well in this particular
situation and story right um this is a
bunch of insurance workers that's the
ironic part okay all right and this one
dude who has apparently been taking
people and leading this exercise doing
this many this exercise many times he
does this trust fall with his group
people and I guess the person that he
was trusting in this moment wasn't
paying attention to the particular
moment great that's why you don't trust
anybody this guy falls he die no he but
he gets paralyzed from the waist down
come on dude why you even do stuff like
that I'm never going to trust you ever
again well let me ask you Joe and was
that guy like come on man give me
another chance I want you to honestly
honestly look into your head and your
heart and your soul let's say Ryan was
that guy all right and then he [__]
wasn't paying attention that trust was
broken you are paralyzed for Life
bro you forgive him depends on what he
says he's going to do to redeem himself
but you're you're paralyzed for you
could ask what would that scenar you're
paralyzed I know what are you going to
do to redeem yourself you just my dick
doesn't work cuz of
you bu you
sword keep
talking what kind of Sword
broadword tungsten tungsten tungsten but
don't you need two handers for a sword
like this guy's like [__] in a chair
it's a waist down right so I could still
like comat com the you might swing this
way and your wheels fly this way if you
don't put the BR on convince your
enemies to come closer oh that's not bad
you taunt it's a lot of taunting all
right all right if you could get me a
sword that I can use with my wheelchair
and you get me a sick ass off-road
wheelchair we'll call it even hey that's
cool I want one of those I'll take one
how about that we both be in whe chairs
like I'll fake it around you that's cool
I'll fake it around you for when people
shave their heads when they're cutting
their girlfriend's cancer head oh yeah
yeah I'll do it you'll break your own
legs for me I won't break them I just
won't use them but your but that dude's
hair will grow back normally well yeah
cuz they're faking around them that's a
joke yeah and also I think I probably
Sue JK for not being ADA
Compliant oh damn way not Ada look at
the way these [__] chairs are that
will not fit that's true that's very
true get it it's not going to fit my
wheelchair dud by the way the way Nick
has needs to s for some reason he sits
there with his chair all the way back
you got to beg him just to walk by here
just go outside beg that's not fire safe
begging for the fire code yeah I mean uh
business 101 let me just ask this
question if you're suing JK isn't your
money going back to you but basically
Bart's being punished by himself then
it's not Joe's problem no I think
somehow Julia is being punished I don't
know Julia owns JK right yeah Julia is
the real the shadow shadow leader Julia
at the top we kind of gave her J cow
there it
is cow oh [__] honestly cow why why do
people do stuff like that it just
doesn't make any sense yeah because when
it works it works when you do it the
real way if you fall it's not a big deal
not from [__] 40 ft tall trust right
now you ever done it before let's do it
let's do trust let's do no no not yet
not yet if we're going to wait wait wait
wait wait what have you ever done trust
in your life well yeah just fall back go
over there that's a
crazy do it from here do it from here
that's paralyzed that's good that's good
someone's being paralyzed wait wait wait
can you see it's don't go until Ryan
says go we're not even employees one
more yeah one more there you go we got
to show no Joe has to be involved so he
can get sued too no I'm watching to make
sure that it works camera should be in
the side you work no way dude Joe you
got to be right here no I can see okay
God damn it be here I don't want to
block I don't want to block
this just fall back and just trust that
we're going to be here this is so
scary jump St ready jump when I say
trust all right 3 2 1
trust
[__] this just committed on this one
just walked away immediately hey you
could have stabbed us stand up now you
could have [__] stabbed us he had a
knife in his pocket
let me stand up
stand bring over here bring him over
here why did you have a you almost
stabbed us with this got it see company
trust all right put his legs down put
his leg hey circumcise him
circumcise hey circumcise him ccum C if
you want to sign up for a retreat and
team building activities contact JK
news.com you had your knife in your
pocket open it was open when it fell
yeah you could have stabbed somebody
that's dangerous that's a lawsuit I
would throw this at you but you might
die we could have ended up on JK news
dude that would have been that's [__]
crazy man 40 ft that that trustfall was
so cool I think we should start a cult
yeah that was really cool I actually
think that dude if we had a cult it
would be one of the coolest Cults like
the in the cult pitch the cult okay well
you have to do trust Falls we're not
going to eat each other out are we huh
going to eat each other out while
falling Ryan while
falling right when you
come yeah I mean that's probably what my
role would be it's like you guys be the
hands that catch and I'll be the mouth
that catches the butt everybody's in a
line Jo's like all right next it's it's
just like Jo's medieval j five six seven
ah yeah are you about to tell us that
the guy actually tried to offer some
form of like like he tried to make up
for it somehow no I knew that this would
be a a more wild story than it actually
is but what's what's heartwarming about
this is he actually forgave the person
he's Christian why is he that's not
heartwarming he's Mormon let's go and
talk about this guy's heroic heart
that's not
heart his name I wouldn't forgive him if
it wasn't Ryan I figured his name is
Zuko Carrasco right he actually leads
these corporate Retreats like time and
time again and which is why it was
probably easy for him to be trusting but
again accidents do happen the paralyze
or the paralyzer paralyze Z oh he was
was the leader of it and he still failed
okay that makes sense what I don't get
it man so his friend was uh wait wait
wait does that mean he was like I'll go
first I'm the leader trust
me and if the guy doesn't do his job and
everyone's watching like oh [__] he be
the ble guy he lost 50 students that
experience so he's 34 he's aged 34 at
the time severely damages his spinal
cord at the bottom of his
and he had just become a dad to his
second daughter one week before get back
inside the tummy I don't trust it I was
just very very scared thinking I have no
way of earning money to take care of my
family I couldn't see my role as a
father in a wheelchair you know I kept
thinking there's no way I can live like
this all right but eventually he says
but then you realize no it was my fault
and that's an amazing I think Discovery
for some it's been your fault dude
that's what happens that's what happens
if you weak to admit it and for the
other person I just think it's very
powerful anybody that constructs any
type of risky kind of experiment like
this yeah idiot it's their fault there's
an element of it not working yeah so
that's the beautiful message it's
actually it's their fault they an idiot
yeah oh that's really nice that's what
we want to let the world know so dumb
yeah I like that monkey never forgive
send this to your friends he did say
quote I still feel like I want to tell
him because I guess that guy isn't
around anymore I still feel like I want
to tell him you know don't feel sorry it
was my mistake it sure was yeah even
though the guy was like uh Corporate
Retreat [__] we got to [__] do these
stupid ass diversity things ropes
[__] fing he's all like all right
whatever that's what I'd be afraid of
the only person in this room I'd be
afraid of and no offense I really mean
this is is if it was Joe
no if if you're standing up there and
it's like you got to do thing and then
all of a sudden behind you you hear he's
like oh [__] I forgot I put a coffee in
and and oh
no all of that in this amount of time I
I would trust Joe I trust Joe you don't
but the thing is Joe's got a 321 trigger
every time we count down to start the
video 32 on one is when he's like I got
to start oh [__] I got a
[__] I got a [__] it's a fact how many
times that happen I can't even
account I'm more safer than all of you
guys so
[Laughter]
sh